okay so in this presentation we're gonna
go over the process known as translation
well here's a very simple diagram of a
ribosome and here comes a big strip of
messenger RNA what the ribosome will do
will read this strip of messenger RNA
and it will signal for transfer RNA to
bring over an amino acid for instance in
this example methionine and one by one
the ribosome will move down the notch of
messenger RNA signal for tRNA transfer
RNA to bring over an amino acid in that
example prolene and one by one the
ribosome will move down a notch
signaling for tRNA to bring over an
amino acid and what is happening here is
the ribosome is linking these amino
acids into a big long chain it's how a
protein is created and eventually the
ribosome will come to a signal that says
stop well of course I kind of just
showed you a lot of the process before
explaining anything so let's go ahead
and jump into this so DNA and
translation if you recall the definition
of a gene it's a small piece of a DNA
molecule that will code for the creation
of a protein in the picture for instance
we have three genes gene a on top for
instance gene a the bracket surrounding
gene a perhaps that's the instructions
to build a protein called hemoglobin in
the middle you can see another small
piece of DNA gene B and you know perhaps
that's the instructions to build a
protein called keratin and so we have to
about 25,000 genes that make up human
DNA and the reason a protein building is
so important and just really a key
fundamental area of biology is because
proteins are used to build our cells our
tissues our organs organ systems
organism and very much our body you can
are you could argue that living
organisms are protein making factories
so we need to understand how proteins
are create
proteins are created through a fairly
complex process of two individual steps
anyone we talked about in a previous
video called transcription and then when
transcription is done that's gonna lead
into today's topic called translation
well let's go ahead and review
transcription just to keep it fresh on
our head so if we take a moment and
review transcription you know here's a
strip of DNA transcription takes place
in the nucleus because that's where DNA
is found if you recall the double helix
of the DNA is broken apart my animated
scissors represent the enzyme called RNA
polymerase and the RNA polymerase prise
apart and breaks apart the double helix
the DNA if you recall from their video
that we that you may have watched
earlier is that transcription happen
what happens next in transcription is
that the messenger RNA nucleotides will
match with the DNA so look at the black
letters on top the a the T the T the C
the C the G on top we're gonna follow a
transcription along the top now as we
make RNA that's what transcription makes
transcription makes RNA you'll notice
that as RNA is being built if there's a
DNA a in black RNA you will match so as
we build Trent as we do the process of
transcription we're building RNA and in
this case we're gonna build messenger
RNA and now that we've reached the end
to step 3 messenger RNA will detach and
we'll move towards a ribosome there it
goes moving towards a ribosome you know
let's go follow that there's the big
strip of red messenger RNA that just
exited from a moment ago and it's about
to go into the cytoplasm so the
messenger RNA will exit the nucleus the
messenger RNA will exit the nucleus and
enter into the cytoplasm and there it's
gonna find a cell part called a ribosome
let's go look
so here's a ribosome and here comes that
strip of red messenger RNA
well once messenger RNA arrives at the
ribosome our next process will begin the
next process is called translation and
that's kind of what the rest of this
video is going to discuss so let's move
on with our topic of today so if you're
in my biology class I gave you one of
these handouts and this is called the
genetic code and what this is it's a
list of what we call messenger RNA
codons so what we're gonna do is we're
gonna group messenger RNA into three
nucleotides at a time three letters at a
time for instance you can see in the
lower left hand corner g ug guanine
uracil guanine that's a codon just above
it you see the codon GU a guanine uracil
adenine that's another codon and what
these codons do is these codons are the
code for amino acids you can see the in
the diagram in the in the chart here the
the name valine in the name alanine in
the name threonine these are the names
of the 20 different amino acids if you
count them all up there'd be 20 of them
starting in the top left phenyl alanine
that's one beneath it is leucine that's
two beneath that it's isoleucine that's
three if you count them all there's
gonna be twenty amino acids and this
chart is an organized diagram that shows
which codon codes for which amino acid
in the lower left-hand corner the codon
G u G will code for the amino acid
called valine and you'll see how this
all works in just a moment and so what
we're gonna show you in a moment is that
the ribosome is going to read messenger
RNA three nucleotides at a time the
messenger RNA is is I should say excuse
me
the ribosome is gonna read one codon at
a time one codon is made from three
nuclei
tights I want to point out a couple
codons of significance in the Box
flashing right now you see the codon Aug
Aug is an important codon because this
is the codon that really activates the
ribosome and really begins this process
when the messenger RNA goes to a
ribosome Aug the ribosome and begins the
process of translation well so if
there's a start codon Aug if Aug is a
start codon there's probably going to be
a code to stop this process and in the
upper right hand corner you can see
there's actually three of them there's
three what are called stop codons so
there's a codon to activate the ribosome
and there's a codon to deactivate the
ribosome and basically let the ribosome
know that the job is finished so let's
go ahead and look at an overview of this
process to see how this works if you
have a copy of this genetic code diagram
right here it's gonna be really helpful
as we go through these notes you can
always google the words genetic code to
print one of these off if you're not in
my biology class so here's an overview
of the process of translation and this
is the animation that we saw at the
beginning on the title screen so
translation if you recall is the process
for how a ribosome makes a protein
proteins are created by the ribosome as
the ribosome performs a process called
translation and this is an overview of
that process so step number one
messenger RNA that was created through
transcription enters the ribosome and so
in the animation here we see that red
strip of messenger RNA that we saw
earlier and notice how there's an Aug
that has entered the ribosome step to
the ribosome is going to read one codon
at a time member codon is made from
three letters three nucleotides and so
if you look on your genetic code chart
find a
gee on your chart any ug has the word
start next to it not only does it have
the word start next to it but it's also
the code for an amino acid transfer RNA
will deliver the amino acid called
methionine because Aug is the code for
methionine so here's tRNA transfer RNA
that red cross shaped object is transfer
RNA and it's carrying that orange circle
labeled methionine and so it transfer
RNA drops off methionine at the ribosome
and the ribosome really just repeats
this process the ribosome moves down a
notch
the ribosome reads the codon CCA if you
look on your chart that you have find
CCA on your chart
it's the amino acid called prolene so
CCA is the code for prolene so transfer
RNA will deliver prolene prolene will
link together with methionine that was
already delivered transfer RNA has done
its job so it'll detent detach the
ribosome just repeats it moves down a
notch the ribosome now encounters GGA
the codon GGA if you look on your chart
look at GGA on your chart and you find
the amino acid called glycine so
transfer RNA will deliver glycine and
the process just keeps repeating tRNA
drops off glycine and now we have a
growing chain of amino acids being built
we have a protein being built the
ribosome moves down a notch to the
fourth codon and if you look in the
picture the fourth codon is ucg if you
look up you see G in your me no acid
chart in your genetic code chart you
find serine you see G is the code for
tRNA to deliver serine and you can see
that's just happened so tRNA will now
drop off serine the ribosome moves down
another notch and the ribosome comes to
the codon G
you you if you find Guu on your amino
acid chart on your genetic code chart
Guu is the codon for valine so the
ribosome is expecting valine transfer
RNA will deliver valine transfer RNA
will release veiling valine excuse me
and the ribosome again moves down a
notch well now we come to something
special here look at at your chart look
find you a a on your chart when you find
you a a that is a stop codon that's the
signal that the process is finished the
ribosome is done building this protein
and what happens is the ribosome
actually breaks apart the messenger RNA
kind of exits and leaves because it's
job is finished and what we're left with
is this chain of one two three four five
amino acids called a protein now in
reality a protein is much larger than
five amino acids proteins can be made
from thousands and thousands of amino
acids but for simplicity this one here
was made from five well this was an
overview there's a few details I left
out that I think are really important I
want to talk about those details now
okay so there's a few important details
that I left out a moment ago in the
overview that I really want to touch on
so first of all some of these notes are
gonna kind of be repetitive what we just
said but then we'll come to some new
information so translation begins when
the mRNA codon Aug is read by a ribosome
so here's a ribosome and here comes our
strip of red messenger RNA now in this
animation noticed that CCU is currently
in the ribosome we the ribosome has yet
to encounter in Aug codon so in this
case that CCU is simply really just
ignored the ribosome hasn't been
activated yet and so one by one the
ribosome will simply move down and be
reading these codons and now now the
ribosome has encountered the Aug and Aug
is the start codon
and if you recall if you look on your
chart you're gonna need that chart again
if you look on your amino-acid chart the
genetic code chart find Aug transfer RNA
is gonna deliver over an amino acid Aug
is the start codon yes but Aug is also
the codon for an amino acid so tRNA
transfer RNA will deliver methionine now
here is a big detail I left out a moment
ago we want methionine Aug is the codon
for methionine that's the only amino
acid that we want if a different
transfer RNA tried to bring in for
instance leucine that can cause a real
big problem so there has to be a way to
prevent mistakes here comes transfer RNA
notice it's carrying methionine as we
want now in this animation I added three
black nucleotides to the transfer RNA I
added UAC
notice how the black UAC is a match it's
the opposite of the red Aug we call the
red messenger RNA letters we call it the
codon transfer RNA possesses what we
call an anticodon anti is a prefix that
means opposite so what's opposite Aug is
UAC transfer RNA in this example has the
anticodon of UAC that's a match that
means methionine will be delivered
so therefore the tRNA delivered
methionine and has just exited the
ribosome will move down a notch and now
look what happened ah look at this
transfer RNA is it's it's reading the
red codon of CCA if you look on your
amino acid chart the red coat on CCA is
prolene I'm supposed to have prolene
right now but transfer RNA is trying to
deliver histidine this is an improper
match this is the wrong amino acid the
protein
could be really affected negatively if
this is allowed to proceed so histidine
in this example is the wrong amino acid
again the red coat on CCA is the amino
acid for prolene that's what I'm
expecting
so because the Red Sea CA conan does not
match the black GU a anticodon watch
what happens
transfer RNA well that will basically
remove itself like the notes say this
prevents the delivery of the wrong amino
acid if you look at again CCA
I'm wanting prolene here's the right
tRNA it has brought proline over notice
how the red CCA codon matches the black
GG you anticodon that's a match tRNA
will deliver prolene and exit the
ribosome moves down a notch
one by one amino acids are linked
together right now the ribosome is
reading TGA find GGA on your chart and
you'll see that's the code for glycine I
want glycine and only glycine here comes
tRNA carrion glycine perfect notice the
red GG a codon noticed the black CCU
anticodon that's a match so therefore
tRNA delivers glycine and one by one
amino acid they're linked together the
ribosome moves down a notch now the
ribosome is reading the red you see G
find you see G on your chart and that
serine I want serine but look transfer
RNA is trying to deliver lysine I don't
want lysine that's not the proper code
but notice how there's an improper match
the red you see G codon does not match
the black uuu anticodon because of this
improper match the transfer RNA that is
carrion
I seen will be removed that's perfect we
don't want lysine you see G I want
serine so the ribosome now is delivered
serine by the proper amino acids cues me
by the proper transfer RNA and so that's
a match and now the ribosome just keeps
moving down a notch find GU you on your
amino acid genetic code chart
Guu is veiling the ribosome wants valine
here it comes transfer RNA is delivered
veiling notice how the the red Guu codon
and the black CAA anticodon they're a
match so transfer RNA detaches the
ribosome moves down a notch the ribosome
comes to UAA that's a stop codon notice
there's even a few letters after the
stop codon there's a CAC after the stop
codon well that CAC really isn't going
to amount to anything because the
ribosome has been stopped the ribosome
will really just kind of break apart and
the TR excuse me the mRNA the red mRNA
will kind of just break apart and
dissolve and what is left is a protein
so translation builds protein but I
really wanted to show you the in detail
because knowing the codon and anticodon
is really important it prevents the
delivery of the room and so here's a
couple practice problems if I were to
give you the DNA letters T G EA you know
pause the video and fill out the mRNA
letters that TGA would create I'm going
to show the answer in 3 2 1
if the DNA letters are TGA the messenger
RNA codon would be AAC you okay again
pause the video if you like and try to
figure out what is the tRNA anticodon if
the messenger RNA is ACU the tRNA
anticodon is UGA okay and now here's
where a lot of mistakes come on the
practice problems I have three groups of
letters up here I have DNA letters I
have mRNA letters and I have tRNA
letters which letters do we
look up on that amino acid chart do I
look up the TGA no that's not there are
no T's on that chart so I'm either
looking up the messenger RNA or the
transfer RNA well let me ask you what
does the ribosome read does the ribosome
read messenger RNA or does the raipur
summary transfer RNA I hope you know the
ribosome reads messenger RNA so you have
to look up the messenger RNA you look up
ACU on your chart and you find the amino
acid called threonine a lot of problems
a lot of mistakes that students have
made in the past come when they look up
the transfer RNA anticodon by mistake
here is another practice problem okay in
this practice problem I've given you the
messenger RNA of a AG pause the video
I'm going to go over the answers to all
three of these boxes in 3 2 1
ok so to work backwards the DNA letters
ttc will lead to the creation of the
mRNA codon AAG once I know the mRNA AAG
the tRNA is just the opposite what's the
opposite of a AG you you see and so now
I have that same problem from a moment
ago do I look up the a AG on the chart
do I look up the u you see on the chart
the ribosome reads messenger RNA so you
look up the messenger RNA the a AG and
you find lysine if you thought the
answer was phenyl alanine that's because
you accidentally looked up you you see
here's one more ok in this in this other
practice problem here pause the video
try to figure out the three boxes I'm
going to go over the answer in three two
one
so if I have you start with the tRNA
anticodon you have to figure out what
messenger RNA codon would have coded for
this I hope you would come up with the
letters G gu and then you have to go
backwards the DNA what DNA letters would
have Allah would have given rise to g gu
and that would be CC
so again now we have to figure out the
amino acid you have your chart in front
of you remember what does the ribosome
read the ribosome reads messenger RNA
you have to look up ggu messenger RNA
and if you do you get glycine if you
thought the answer was prolene that's
because you accidentally looked up CCA
here's another good practice problem you
know pause this pause this and try to
answer these three questions and so here
is a big strip of our of messenger RNA
that just entered that ribosome there in
order try to answer these three
questions I'm gonna go over the answers
in three two one
so the answer to number one lists the
amino acids that will be delivered to
this ribosome there they are
Pro signing and then prolene and then
serine and then prolene again and then
glycine and then serine again let me
explain that first codon is a ga you the
ribosome will ignore that Aug is the
start codon tRNA will deliver methionine
the ribosome simply moves down a notch
and comes to CCG CCG is the code for the
amino acid prolene
so prolene is delivered the ribosome
moves down a notch
AG you look on your chart fine AG you
transfer RNA brings over serine the
ribosome moves down a notch the ribosome
is reading CCA fine CCA on your chart
that's the code for the amino acid
prolene and one by one the ribosome
moves down a notch reading codons GGA
look on your chart GGA is the code for
glycine and the ribosome again moves
down a notch and now the ribosome comes
to you see you that's the code for
serine and eventually the ribosome gets
to the end UGA look on your chart UGA is
a stop codon and so the process is
finished well question number two what
is the anticodon for each
the anticodon again are just the
opposite of the codon
and so the opposite of Aug the first
anticodon is UAC so the anticodons are
opposite of the codon in question number
three when finished how many amino acids
in size is this protein will count them
up there are six amino acids so there
you go if you're in my biology class you
know try these problems right here and
I'd be happy to check your answers
either before school or after school so
go ahead and pause the video and work
these out good luck